Thank you.
I'm looking out a hotel suite window in the capital of Congo
in the middle of Africa.
There are bullet marks on the buildings, out there, because war is raging.
But it's nighttime and quiet. There's a nasty
cockroach infestation in the kitchen and a putrid smell in the air.
I've turned the T.V. volume up loudly because the Congolese government has bugged
our
room.
I turn and face
Shaka. She's a woman from Kenya with the brown skin of the coastal people
and thick black hair and intense dark eyes. Tears are welling in her eyes
and she's pleading with me. "SASHA. We have to take these people
along with the rest.
If we don't, they'll die here, and their blood will be on our hands. Please.
You have to trust me." I'm facing a terrible decision
and I'm afraid no matter what I do people are going to be
killed.
A month earlier in Kenya, my boss David---at the International Organization
for Migration where we worked--called me into his office. He handed me
a list with one hundred twelve names on
it and told me he was sending me into the Congo, on a rescue mission.
The job was to evacuate one hundred and twelve massacre survivors.
He warned me really explicitly that under no circumstances could I
include anybody else on that list. If I did, we would fail to get
anyone out and they would all
die.
David knew because he'd spent the past six months in the Congo evacuating people.
I'd met one teenage girl that he pulled out--she had these nervous eyes-- and she
told me that the killing started when the President of Congo went on
T.V. and said that all people of the Tutsi tribe are the enemy and need to be hunted
down and exterminated.
It was an extension of the role of Rwandan genocide in
ways. This teenage girl went into hiding that day but had to
eventually come out to look for food and as she was sneaking around town she saw a
mob chased down and catch another woman, and they put a tire over her body pinning
her arms to her side and doused her in gasoline and set her on fire.
They were killing people in terrible ways because Tutsis were seen as the scapegoats for the
Congo's problems.
This teenage girl had lost her own parents, but she had four brothers who were still alive and they
were on the list that David handed
me.
David also warned me about Shaka. She'd been on every previous mission with him.
But he told me that I couldn't trust her, that she always tried to include additional people and I had to stop
her from doing that.
that.
Shaka and I flew into the Congo and we rented a car and a driver and went to the
safe compound where the hundred and twelve were gathered.
These big black gates swung open as our car drove into this two acre
compound with ten foot walls and jagged shards of glass topping the walls.
There were guards with AK- 47's slung at their sides standing around.
A one brick story building (a one story building) was in the middle and a
large tent off to the side and latrines on another side.
Somebody saw Shaka and all the sudden there was a mob around our car and they were pushing it up and
down and chanting her name and I remember David telling me that
people are going to go crazy with
relief when they see you because they think they're going to die there. And when they see you they'll
know there's another flight. But it felt really scary and out of control for me
because they were away more people than one hundred and twelve on our
list.
We sat a table up on the top of a little hill and the crowd gathered below and I
called people up one at a time and I took their name and their birth date and their photo
and I told them we'd be flying them out in a few days time; I had to give this information to the
Congolese immigration officials.
I got really excited when I saw the four brothers of that teenage girl come up.
When
we were done in trying to leave a guy who was working in the compound said " before you leave you
have to go into that tent over there and look at the people who just came
in and I thought, I don't want to see anybody else, we can't take them, so why even look.
But my feet were walking towards the tent as I was thinking that and I stepped inside
and it was like time stopped.
It was really hot in that tent and I remember the sweat trickling down
the small of my back. But what struck me was how
completely quiet it was--which seemed impossible because there
were thirty two widows and orphans standing and sitting in that tent.
A guy who brought us in leaned into me and said, " They were in a prison camp for sixteen
months where most of their family members were executed we don't know how they survived."
They all looked traumatized and imaciated and they had these
hollow stares like there was nothing behind their eyes.
Shaka leaned down to a little girl holding a doll and said, "Let me see
your doll".  And all the sudden the doll's eyes popped open
and its tongue lolled out of its
mouth and we realized it was an infant child that looked more dead than
alive.
I went over to a thirteen year old boy and said, " What's your name?" And
another smaller boy grabbed his hand and said,  "He doesn't talk anymore, I talk for
him". That 13 year old had been brutalised so badly he just
stopped speaking. Shaka and I left, and that night, in the
hotel room she was holding the list of widows and orphans and begging me to take them.
I held the list of a hundred twelve and I said, "We
can't.' But I wondered,  "Can I live with myself
if we leave these widows and orphans here and they're
killed?"
No, I didn't think so but could I live with myself if we tried to take them
and we failed to get everybody out and they all
died? No.
And then I thought about who Shaka was, she had like this clear  moral orientation,
she did what was right in her heart and wasn't concerned about personal gain
or
recognition. And then I wondered, "who am I"?
My great grandmother had come to the U.S. as a refugee fleeing anti-Semitism in Russia and she was
a widow who raised four orphans or four children on her own.
I've been working with refugees since graduating from college six years earlier but nothing had prepared me
for this. And then Shaka I said words that changed me,
"Sasha, we're humanitarians. We're here on the ground now. If
we don't do this these people will be forgotten and they'll die here. This is up to us.
It's our
decision". And in that moment I
trusted her.
So I called David. And he got really angry when we told him what we wanted to do he said,
"Listen, I'll tell you exactly what's going to happen. You have to tell the Congolese immigration
authorities and then they're going to include their own people on your list. And then the last minute,
maybe even on
the plane they'll pull your people off and you won't get anybody out. You can't do this".
And I said, "David I get it, but we have to try. And he was quiet and
then I heard him say, "OK, and here's what you have to do. This is a U.S. rescue mission
so get the U.S. ambassador's approval. I try it.
We got the U.S. ambassador's approval. And then, on the last night as the sun was setting
we went to see the head of Congolese immigration (a stocky man with
beady eyes who'd already told us how much he hated Tutsis).
When we told him we were taking the widows and orphans, he said that he had seven additional people
we had to take. And we said that's fine. And then he pulled out this whole
new list and said he also wanted to take all these other people,
and we said," we can't". And we argued with them. And we even tried to bribe 'em. But as
we were leaving all they said was, "I'm in charge here. I say
who leaves and who stays.
We'll just see what happens tomorrow."
Those words terrified
me.
Back in the hotel we realize we had another big problem- we had too many people
for our flight. But then we thought that the children all looked so emaciated
that we could change the birth dates and make all the four and three year olds less than two
and in that way we'd free up enough seats.
So I spent the night doing that and at three AM,as I tried to close my eyes,
I couldn't sleep I was so wired with exhaustion and fear
and the uncertainty of it all. I thought, "Have we just condemned everyone
to death with this
decision?"
A few hours later I went and got four buses and I had four armed
guards per bus and I went to the safe compound. And we started loading everybody on and the people who weren't
coming started yelling. And one man grabbed me and he pulled my face close to his and he said,
"Sasha, you have to take me with you! Look at my face. I'm a Tutsi. I'll be killed here".
But we couldn't take him or so many others. And their cries
faded into the distance as our busses pulled
out. And now my heart jumped in my throat because this was the most dangerous part of the
entire
mission. The Congalese government had told us that they would let us do this but
unofficially they didn't want us to succeed. And I worried that maybe a mob would attack our bus.
Or maybe gunmen would start shooting from around a corner. Hundreds of thousands of people had lost
their lives already and no one would notice a few
more. An hour later we finally pulled into the
airport and we stopped fifty feet away from the plane and I thought," There's the plane. Let's just get
everybody on that plane."
Congolese immigration police hustled me and Shaka off the buses and.
Then they started checking people using the documentation we had given. And as the widows and
orphans came down they stopped them.
And I had this terrible thought, "Oh my God, these people are witnesses to terrible atrocities
and the Congolese immigration police aren't going to let them leave because they don't want them talking about what they've
seen". I
thought," Everything that David said is coming true right now". And I felt so helpless and I looked
around for Shaka and she was talking to the head of Congolese immigration and waving her
arms and the seconds tick by. And then they
let them off the bus. And they boarded the plane and we all boarded the plane.
And I
stepped on last. And the cabin had turned into a furnace because the plane had
been sitting on the tarmac for a couple of hours. And it was so
packed with people. They were so many children sitting on laps of adults.
The door shut behind me. And I felt the plane engines rumble to life.
And cool air came into the cabin. And we started down the runway. And we lifted off the
ground.
I'd imagined that in that moment people would erupt into cheers
of joy because they were finally
safe. But when I looked everyone was crying for the people we
had left behind.
It was at once the most joyous and heartbreaking moment.
And in that moment I thought about Shaka pleading with me in the hotel.
And I was so
thankful. We couldn't get everyone out but we got those on our list
out and those widows and orphans and they were the worst off. I looked at the
tiny infant. And there was a thirteen year old
boy. And there were the four brothers who are going to be reuniting with their teenage
sister
soon. And as their eyes met mine I felt
this incredible sense of connection and shared humanity
sink into the deepest core of who I am. And that feeling
has motivated and inspired me ever since.
applause
you.